well guys as promised I am back talking
about the worst horror remakes and
sequels
I actually rewatched these past few days
have been hard my scary movie special
part 1 and part 2 is currently up and
I've been getting a lot of really good
feedback from you guys I'm very very
very proud of that and I thank you very
much for all the next things you've said
in that I promised I talked to you guys
about these I don't know why I did that
but here I am let's talk about them what
I'm going to be doing is going to be
presenting a top 5 or bottom 5 whatever
way you want to look at it of both
horror remakes horror sequels will go
back and forth for each one so let's
start off with the fifth worst horror
sequel of all time in my opinion of
course and as usual if your pick is not
on this list I apologize this is in my
opinion welcome to the Internet number
five worst horror sequel the ring -
somehow this movie is actually directed
by the original director of the original
film the Japanese version what happened
this is a completely unscary movie
nothing about this movie was disturbing
or creepy like the first one it wasn't
even interesting it was horribly shot -
that was the most shocking thing to me
this one shot early on the film that
like zooms in really fast on the kid's
head when he realizes he's about to die
it was so bad it looked like a
made-for-tv movie from like 1998 okay
number five worst horror remake of all
time and Nightmare on Elm Street I've
actually heard legitimate people who
have said I liked that movie Chris why
are you hating on it I don't understand
why you liked it that's cool that's your
opinion man but let me give you this
little bit of knowledge Rooney Mara the
star of this movie has publicly said
that this movie almost made her quit
acting she hated the experience of
making this film so much and the
eventual product that turned out from
her work that she almost quit acting
entirely this movie is so horrible it's
a Thai movie that just is like well
we'll just do a couple shots that were
in the original film or like tribute
them actually copy off them completely
will make the fans happy with like the
hand coming out of the bathtub and
everything will do stuff like that
they'll like that stuff and then we'll
add like this backstory where Freddy is
a child more
they completely missed what made the
first film great which was the tone the
creepiness the unsettling the dreamlike
state the cool fantasy like element of
it all gone from this movie okay for the
fourth worst horror sequel I almost put
Halloween three season of the witch
because a lot of people view that is one
of the worst of this series because it
does not even contain Michael Myers in
it but then I realize you know what at
least they had the respect to say
Michael Myers died and the second one
will leave him dead will go a different
direction they at least tried not to
make it some consistently reappearing
ghostly killer that he eventually became
with absolutely no suspense or no scares
whatsoever they at least tried to go in
a different direction movie still sucked
big time but to me the most offensive
Halloween sequel is actually Halloween
resurrection it's the one where in the
opening scene spoiler warning spoiler
warning don't watch in these movies huh
they were like Jamie Lee Curtis can you
come back this movie and she's like sure
if you kill me off okay we'll have
Michael Myers come back in the opening
scene and kill you because you went nuts
because you actually did not kill him at
the end of Halloween h2o that was a
random guy wearing a Michael Myers mask
and now you're tortured by that and so
you're in a mental institution
Michael Mars is going to come back and
stab you and then walk away that's the
horrible part of the movie right no
actually it contains Busta Rhymes
karate-chopping Michael Myers through a
window
me huh fuck this movie okay the fourth
worst horror remake of all time this is
a movie that I admittedly didn't even
finish couldn't even sit through this
movie I watched part of it and I said to
myself I can't take this anymore
I cannot take any more of the fog the
remake of John Carpenter's film contains
nothing that made the original film fun
now I'll admit the fog is possibly a
movie that could be remade I didn't
think it was a terrific amazing movie it
was a suitably creepy movie where I
thought the nighttime scenes were very
well directed and very creepy but the
daytime scenes I felt were very
uninteresting with characters that just
were just kind of there like Jamie Lee
Curtis was just kind of in the movie I
didn't really find her character that
interesting I thought you know what that
could actually maybe be remade and
actually maybe be better no I'm not
really fan because I got a director in
there with absolutely no vision he's
just like hey let's get some guy to
press record on the camera and he'll do
the movie right yeah okay good I will
get the guy from Smallville yeah that's
how we'll do this cheesy special-effects
uninteresting characters no scares
horrible movie there are a lot of Friday
of 13th movies there's quite a bit of
them in fact the original Friday of 13th
I think it's kind of not even really all
that great it's just kind of like this
cult classic movie where people can
watch it and have fun with it I don't
really consider it really that good to
be honest but at least it didn't take
place in space
like Jason X it's in space it's in space
that's really all I have to say by this
movie takes place in space on to the
third worst horror remake of all time
speaking of the last film franchise
Friday the 13th the remake this is a
movie that again just like Nightmare on
Elm Street they're like well we don't
really have to remake it right we can
just kind of like we'll call it that and
we'll say it's a remake but it's not
it's just jason killing people again and
we want to use the original title and
put a whole bunch of needless and never
ending sex scenes in there that will get
the teens in the seat right yes okay
good
oh and lots of blood please but make it
be really dumb and we need Jason to set
booby traps that's what we need we need
Jason to set booby traps and blood right
and some boobies yes we need the boobies
and the booby traps that's what we need
right good there's a checklist for these
types of movies and this movie has them
all it's porn with Jason jaws the
revenge or jaws for as you might like to
call it movie stars Lorene gray who at
the time was apparently or maybe still
is I don't know married to the president
of universal I wonder how she ended up
in this movie this movie also has
Michael Caine the poor man somehow he's
in this movie a ruby the size of a
tangerine wonder how they kill the shark
in this movie yeah they put like a sonar
thing like in his mouth that emits like
this signal that makes him come out of
the water and like Bob on his tail fin
and go barely sharks have vocal cords
and they growl a lot and as it's bobbing
on its tail fence somehow like just
balancing the boat rams it now at one
version Jesus explodes he just explodes
I don't know why but there's like
another version out there that I saw on
TV one Saint is on YouTube where the
boat like Pierce's him and the bloods
everywhere and then he just like falls
down into the water
terrible movie in every regard though
it's the type of movie related just have
the mechanical shark pop up everyone
well have Laureen gray talk about how
Roy Scheider died yeah let's just make
Roy Scheider die there's a great idea
let's take one of the coolest characters
ever and just kill him it's chief Brody
he's still alive trust me he's alive
hey man Hooper swam to the ocean and in
Jaws two he rescued those kids and he's
happily living that's where he is right
now now on to the second worst horror
remake of all time the 1998 version of
psycho or should I just say the 1960
version colorized starring Vince Vaughn
Julianne Moore and Haitian big ol
Mortensen directed by Gus Van Sant's the
term shot-for-shot is sometimes used
kind of loosely where they're like yeah
they kind of redid certain scenes the
same way no this movie literally is a
shot-for-shot remake they actually tried
to recreate every single shot in Alfred
Hitchcock's original psycho what in the
world is the point of that who thought
that was gonna be a good idea hey let's
make psycho and have Vince Vaughn be the
guy why we just make the Exorcist again
and have Olin Wilson played the girl
whom Ian won't be possessed Wow I'm
being possessed Wow that's there's no
point to this movie it's so bad like
inserted pictures of pigs in the middle
of the shower scene where is that even
me wasn't what okay so the number one
worst horror sequel ever oh my god troll
- I watched troll 2 under the best
circumstances ever I had like 5 friends
and we had like popcorn and soda and
candy and we liked Friday night we
watched it it was pretty amazing it's a
funny movie it's the most like
unintentionally hilarious movie it's
it's incredibly but it is truly awful
it's like the kind of movie where you
can tell everyone who was filming it was
like behind the scenes going like my
career is over and I'm going to die one
of the scenes it isn't really that
widely publicized it is actually pretty
amazing it's the scene where the kid
feels like hey oh my parents are frozen
they're all frozen
I have to pee on them to unfreeze them
and he almost does I remember that scene
oh boy
troll - I mean even the first troll was
pretty awful had Julia Louise drive to
Center
that's about all in had there's even a
documentary called best worst movie and
it's all about troll 2 it's pretty
entertaining check that out alright guys
so the worst horror remake ever oh no
not the babies not the bees ah Wow
starring Nicolas this is also very
unintentionally hilarious movie that I
very much enjoy watching to be honest
because it is so funny where else can
you see Nicolas Cage in a bear suit
punching a woman you can't see that
anywhere else this is like the epitome
of we were trying to make a serious
movie and it just didn't work there are
movies like that like the room
admittedly this film has better acting
than the room but I am so entertained by
Nicolas Cage I can't explain why I just
love the guy I think he's awesome Rose
Byrne was in the film knowing with him
and she was talking about how Nicolas
Cage and her were about to go on a press
conference and he turned to her and he
was like I'm gonna do this whole press
conference without saying the word I
only Nicolas Cage man but the Wicker Man
is truly amazingly awful it's pretty
great you bitches you're bitches and
it's funny because you can only get the
amazing ending on the DVD that whole B
thing was actually cut from theaters
obviously and why I know why they did
that but they put it in the DVD thank
goodness because it's amazing well guys
there you go if you want to have a
Halloween filled with absolute crap
watch some of those movies there's
plenty of other ones I could have put on
like say American Psycho - or the
Halloween remake by Rob Zombie there's a
lot of things I could have mentioned in
this list I didn't mention but those are
some of the ones that were most
offensive to me so guys my scary movie
special part 1 & 2 is currently up if
you'd like to watch that if you haven't
seen that yet and a separate video that
contains only the skits from those
videos all 20 minutes of them because we
work very hard on those we'd love to
hear any thoughts you have thanks very
much as always for watching guys and if
you liked this you can click right here
and get stuck mine eyes